oh his story is incredible literally
gos Santos is the modern day Walter
Mitty at the heart of government
he's the congressman who's told why
after why the courts will test his
latest assertion that he's not guilty of
charges against him I appreciate
leadership for being patient at this
time and for allowing the process to
play out I think this is about innocent
until proven guilty this starts I have
my right to fight to prove my innocence
as the government has a right to fight
to try to find me guilty in whatever
on the campaign Trail Santos told a
Litany of lines including that he was an
ex-warf Street Banker who'd graduated
from prestigious colleges none of it was
true
Mr Santos do your lies make a mockery of
this place and of the American people
what would it take for you to resign Mr
Santos pardon me guys
is there a public is the Republican
Party tainted by your fabrication sir
appreciate it good to see you should the
public believe anything you say thank
you
Santos has admitted to lying on his CV
but it hasn't stopped him keeping his
seat in the House of Representatives
Republican power Brokers know that his
removal would threaten their slim
majority I will
story has shifted to the court the
charges he faces include spending
political donations on himself claiming
unemployment benefit when he was in fact
employed and of lying to the House of
Representatives regarding his financial
affairs his political opponents have
delivered their holding verdict we're
digesting the the charging documents but
the level of fraud the level of
extremism uh the the continued you know
lies throughout all of this it's just an
unfortunate thing that um that we're all
colleagues together and this level of
fraud that's been perpetrated on the
people of New York the reality is is
sorry it's a Witch Hunt because
it makes no sense that in four months
four months five months I'm indicted
this latest twist and the Curious tale
of George Santos presents one hard truth
he might yet swap the seat of power for
a spell in prison
James Matthews Sky News in Washington